you know I have been very fortunate to
work in a company that has a large
percentage of women i get i don't know
if it's a San Francisco company or if
it's a reflection of my father and being
very inclusive to very purpose oriented
company company and has really strong
values that we talk about one of those
values being teamwork and so I don't
know if it's just part of my DNA but
team building and being inclusive of
other people and their thoughts and
respectful to me is is really key to
leadership and and having people follow
you is letting them feel a part of the
process the other key I think the
difference or important component to
leadership is is having passion and
really caring about what you would you
do and feeling like you're making a
difference and and I think whether
you're a man or a woman having that and
having people surround you who share
that passion you can do you know
unbelievable things and that's really
some of the disciplines or values that I
have used in my own work and and found
successful and I'll have to say you know
for my father same thing you know he
really was passionate about
democratizing investing he did not like
the way Wall Street treated the average
American so he created a business that
was more inclusive and helped more
Americans and I guess in some ways I
followed that somehow you know again I I
really related to that and try to take
it to a whole different level by
including or making investing more
accessible for for women for
disadvantaged populations and you know
others who may not have access and it's
rewarding and it makes you want to work
harder
I absolutely do think there's there's
definitely sexism in the workplace I
think it's critical for women to take
note of that and not work for a company
that that has that allows those kind of
behaviors to occur you know we do have
control over that we don't have to
participate in it and there are plenty
of companies who value women and what
they have to offer as we know a diverse
workplace makes a stronger company and
you know you hear a lot also about women
who get disenchanted with the business
world and they go and create their own
businesses I say go do it you know we
have a lot to offer and don't let
anything stop
you